HE HAD A 7-POINT GAME.
WILL DROP IT OFF FOR SHAYNE
GOSTISBEHERE.
BRADY TKACHUK TAKES THE PUCK
AWAY.
COMES IN PICKS IT UP AND DRIVES
IT.
TOO MANYELEBRATION THAT'S FOR
SURE.
THE COYOTES ON THE POWER PLAY AS
IT IS SHAYNE GOSTISBEHERE.
THAT WILL FEED
ON THIS ONE.
HERE IT COMES WHIPPING IN
KESSEL WALKS IN.
DROPPED IT FOR GOSTISBEHERE.
MISSED IT.R THE LINE.
THAT'S AN OFFSIDE AGAINST THE
COYOTES.
RIGHT AS THE PENALTY EXPIRES. A
BREAK OFF THE DRAW.
AND SCORES! DRAWS.
THE STICK SNAPPED ON THE
FACECE GAMES.
SECOND FASTEST TO HIT THE ORSTE.
>> Garry: POWER PLAY. FOR WHITE.
BACK FOR STÜTZLE.OF THE
STICK OF ZUB AND BACK IN THE
OTTAWA ZONE.
>> John: 10 SHOTS FOR OTTAWA IN.
MOSER AFTER IT..
MOSER.
>> Garry: THIS LINE THE BEST
LINE FOR ARIZONA
GALCHENYUK, GOES DOWN IN THE
C.
AND IT IS CROUSE SHORT-HANDED.
GOING TO THE NET! POST.
STRALMAN MAKES THE SAVE.
THE PUCK ROTATATHAD IT POKED OF.
WEDGEWOOD's STICK.
AND THEN THIS FAKE
BRADY TKACHUK TO THE NET.
WEDGEWOOD.
REBOUND.
SCORES!B.
THERE'S ANOTHER INDIRECT FROM
CONNOR BROWN IN BACK-TO-BACK
GAMES AND THIS
BACKHAND PASS FROM KELLER.
KOLYACHONOK WAS THERE.
TYLER ENNIS.
ENNIS THROWS IT RIGIG
TIPPED BY STÜTZLE GOES WIDE!
SWSWT
FOR A TIP.
THEY DID ACCOMPLISH THAT.
IT JUST DIDN'T HIT THE NET.